الى الطاهر المرضي اذا ما كنا نستطيع على
الاستماع اليكم مره اخرى كنا نجد صعوبه في
ذلك الطاهر تفضل
نعم نحن في جنوب الخرطوم في تحديدا في حي
ابو ادم هذا هنا هنالك هدوء حذر يحاول
المواطنون هنا الحصول على الخبز خاصه وان
هنالك اصطفاف لهذا في هذا المخزب المخبز
للحصول على حاجاتهم من الخبز وهي من السلع
الضروريه التي اصابها جحف كبير في هذه
اللحظات ويحاول كثير من المواطنين الحصول
على هذا الامر ويبدو ان هنالك كثير من
الصعاب في هذا الاطار ولكن يبدو ان الذين
الان وصلوا الى مكان الخبز والشراء
المباشر طلعوا من المحظوظين
يمكننا ان اسمع كيف هي معاناه المواطنين
للحصول على الخبز وكثير من المواد
الغذائيه في ظل ظروف الحرب والاشتباكات
والله الوضع متازم وصعوبه انجاز وحركه في
التنقلات الداخليه
الحمد لله الصف يعني الصفوف متازمه كما
ترى في الصوره كثير من الناس معانا يعني
حتى لو اخذت اخذ الكميه الكامله يعني عندك
اسره كامله كثير من الاسر نزحت الى
الولايات
نحمد الله على
خير ان شاء الله
حصه المواطن من الخبز محدوده يعني لا
يستطيع المواطنه يشتري الكميه من الخبز
التي يريدها في مثل هذه الظروف حتى تتاح
الفرصه لاكبر عدد من المواطنين كذلك كيف
هو الوضع كيف يعني تسيرون حياتكم اليوميه
في مثل والله الحمد لله
لكن الحمد لله الامور ماشيه فاتح لكن
الحمد لله ماشي الامور تمام
واحده من الاشياء التي يرون فيها انها
ايجابيه ان يكون هنالك مخبز فاتح يعني
ويقوم بهذا العمل ويقدم لهم وان كان يعني
بالقليل يعني كيف يعيش المواطن ظروف يعني
تسير الامور بشكل يومي خاصه السلعه
الضروريه كالخبز وغيره بسم الله الحمد لله
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله نحن سكان
ابو ادم مربع اربعه ولا فدواتهم كلهم
مجتمع ابو ادم الحمد لله الاشياء موجود
موفره لكن الاسعار عاليه جدا جدا يعني
الناس بقت ما قادره تشتري وفي التطبيقات
بتاعت البنوك والحاجات دي اغلبيتها ما
شغاله الكهرباء تطبيقاتها ما شغاله
الخضروات والحاجات دي كلها بتسجل لكن
بتيجي باسعار طائله جدا جدا والناس اموال
الموجوده في اليوبا كلها خلصت ما اعرفها
تجيب من وين يعني لكن احنا كابو ادم نحمد
ربنا حمدا كثيرا جدا جدا عندنا الكهرباء
متوفر والمهم متوفره بكميات هايله الحمد
لله بس نحن بقت مشكلتنا في انه الكاش
نجيبه من وين يعني دي المشكله الاساسيه
يعني نحن من الطالب الاطراف المتنازعه
سواء كان الفريق برهان او الفريق انه
الناس زي ما هم مهتموا بانه
الجاليات الاجنبيه دي كلها يقلوها
ويؤمنونها المسارات الامنه نحن بنطلب انه
بس يدونه عشره في المئه من الاهتمام الدول
الاجانب يدل المواطنين عشان نحن نقدر نقلي
ناسنا المرضانين والجثث الموجوده في
الشوارع ونحن زادنا نقدر نحن المواليه
تجينا والامداد يجينا في الافران ويجينا
في المحلات التجاريه نحن دايرين اهتمام من
الجهاز لانه هم مسؤولين الدوله ربنا
بيسالهم منا نحن يعني هم يهتموا بالاجانب
واخ
قادرين ناس
نحن بنرفع يدنا العالمين اتقوا الله في
الشعب السوداني يا احمدوه يا برهان البتاع
اللي فوق ده كله في رقبتكم اي روحت او اي
انسان مريض ما يلقى علاج او يمشي يغسل
الكلى ما يلقى محل عشان المركز بتاع غسيل
ما يلقى بنادول عشان يتعالج ولا ادفع
الحاجات يتعالجها رقبتكم انتم ونحن ربنا
سبحانه وتعالى انه الليله لرب العالمين
منكم انتم الاتنين ليل اذا كان عندكم
حاجه تقدموها بالله زي ما بقولوا يعني
نقطونا بانه خلوه غيركم يجي يمشي البلد دي
لانه ما ممكن الحاصل ده مستحيل يعني يحصل
يعني السودان فيها موارد فيها كل شيء نسال
الله العفو والعافيه نسال الله انه يحقن
دماء الشعب السوداني ويحكي مع ابناء الشعب
السوداني يجمع كلمته ونوحي الصفهم والسلام
عليكم ورحمه الله هذا يتحدث عن شوح
السيوله وهذه واحده من الاشياء المهمه
جدا والضروريه التي اصبحت هنالك فيها كثير
من المعاناه والتفاقم الازمه وليس الرجال
وحدهم من يصطفون للحصول على الخبز ايضا
النساء تعاني في هذه اللحظات ايضا للحصول
على الخبز للاستفاده من الهدنه التي يعني
تمت في هذا الاطار كيف هو الوضع عندكم في
[موسيقى]
اظن ان احنا
المتضررين بالنسبه انه للحكم للسلطه اي
واحد يفوز لا نحن المتضررين ده انت شايف
بعينك الحاصل شنو الحياه اليوميه وكيف لمن
يعني نحن نكون عايزين نطلع على الشارع
يعني الواحد بيكون خايف انه يجيب اكله
يجيب ميته ويجيب شراب وخايف انه تجيب حاجه
يعني الزول بيكون خايف شديد حتى يعني
الاطفال متضررين ان احنا متضررين الشديد
من الحاصل ده يعني كل يوم احنا ما نقدر
ننوم يعني ممكن الواحد بيكون خايف من
الرصاص اللي في اذانه
بالنسبه للحصول على
الجانب الصحي او انسان يحتاج للمستشفى او
اي غير كيف هي الامور والله يعني ابو ادم
كويسه لكن
من الجانب يمشي المستشفيات انه يعني شوف
الحاصل في الشوارع يخاف انه في عصابات
متفلته يخاف من انه يعني يحصل له حاجه انت
انك سايق سيارتك تمشي في الشارع تخافي انك
تكون شايل سلاح لانه تقع عصابه متفلته
يعني ياخذوا سيارتك يضربوك يعني الناس
تخاف شديد
شكرا جزيلا